a shocking allegation of jury
intimidation on day three of
deliberations in the kyle rittenhouse
trial as the jury heads home once again
for the night msnbc looking like
complete fools today after the judge
banned the liberal network from the
courtroom for doing this very stupid
thing watch
a person who identified himself as james
j morrison
and who claimed that he was a producer
with nbc news stated that he had been
instructed by ms bion
in new york to
follow the jury bus he was ticketed for
violating a traffic control signal
i have instructed that no one from msnbc
news will be permitted in this building
for the duration of this trial
this is a very serious matter
smooth move xlax the msnbc freelancer
who followed the jury bus now getting
thrown under the bus the network
releasing a statement claiming the
producer never intended to contact or
photograph the jurors and saying they
regret the incident and will cooperate
with authorities how serious is this
jesse
well it's serious because he got caught
it's probably a stringer who's trying to
land an exclusive for the today show all
big networks
they're just loaded up with cash and
they have a bunch of these people just
all over kenosha right now trying to
identify a juror and then get that great
access because that first juror
interview is going to be the interview
no matter how this thing shakes out but
the fact that he ran a red light while
he was tailing the jury i mean that is a
dangerous traffic situation and you
don't want to endanger any of the jurors
so that's why it was so serious but just
in the beginning of this thing the way
they
misreported the blake thing sparked the
riots then had the msnbc reporter
outside saying mostly peaceful with the
flames shooting up the sky and then just
smearing this defendant as a white
supremacist and now endangering the
lives of the jury if you could just take
msnbc out of this entire last year in
kenosha we would have a much more
peaceful and safer place interesting um
now geraldo yes kennedy what is going on
with the jury because obviously they're
on day three of their deliberation they
have gone home for the day we understand
that one of the jurors has asked to take
the instructions home with them how
sweet so tell me what could possibly be
going on here what are the different
scenarios say bob what do you think of
this what should i do well sarah i don't
know uh i i
don't know obviously my my surmise is
that things are not going well for the
defendant because if they were on the
road to an easy acquittal i think that
would have happened you've had 24 hours
of deliberation so i think that what's
happening is that there is a negotiation
perhaps a compromise a debate of whether
to go with one of the lesser included
charges rather than the more serious
charges the first degree charges so it
could be that it could be that someone
is hung that someone doesn't know or
doesn't want to go along with the
majority and is saying you know i want
an acquittal and you want a conviction
or vice versa the human dynamic gets
more gummy gets more complicated the
longer they are out now there comes the
weekend uh the the
tailing the stalking by the nbc
freelancer although i'm right i think
jesse's absolutely right that every
network does it that stalking i believe
is some something that information will
get to the jurors they will know that
something happened because they are not
sequestered which to me is a monumental
error they should have been sequential
thank you a case of this serious nature
uh they should have been
at least when they began deliberations
sequestered at that point so i believe
that is one of the many errors in this
case the defense by moving for a
mistrial without prejudice is basically
saying uh listen let's just do this
again and you don't say that when you're
ahead you say that when you're behind
interesting so let's talk a little bit
about what the defense is petitioning
from the court how likely are we to see
a mistrial declared and will that happen
after there is a verdict i think less
likely at this point because the judge
has specifically said that he might want
to hold an evidence hearing with
testimony from experts as to exactly
what defense is arguing disadvantage
them meaning the drone footage the the
version of evidence that they got the
version of the video was compressed it
was a smaller volume and it was less
quality and so the judge essentially
wants to ascertain okay was this
prejudicial how much so and he would
need to rely on expert testimony to that
fact he's also not heard a rebuttal yet
from prosecution to that motion but to
your point you know originally the
defense was arguing and they maintained
this argument that there has been
prosecutorial overreach this entire time
they said it's been intentional in bad
faith it's prejudiced the defendant and
at that point they were arguing with
prejudice to dismiss it with prejudice
uh to attribute they can't be retried
correct and then they changed their
minds which is an interesting turn event
or at least submitted differently and at
the time they argued we don't want to
give the prosecution another kick at the
cat and i think what's interesting about
it is that in the court of public
opinion the butt for analysis is pretty
strong right it's different than the
court of the actual court of justice but
it's interesting because given another
shot prosecution might actually nail it
so i would think defense would you know
want to do everything within their realm
within their power to prevent that from
happening keep in mind final point that
the judge can do a whole host of other
um remedial items or remedial actions uh
toward the prosecution short of vacating
a verdict right so he can help them
he'll hold them in contempt he can
reprimand them formally etc sanctions uh
that don't rise to the level of actually
vacating let's say a potential uh
acquittal can he take away library cards
convictions that's that's actually much
more serious and
he couldn't he he wouldn't uh vacate an
acquittal yeah that would be the
jefferson but he could vacate conviction
oh that's exciting um well clearly this
has been tried in the court of
msnbc uh let's take a look at joy reid
with her expert legal analysis watch
greg's favorite it's car written house
trial
it reminded a lot of people of something
the brett kavanaugh hearings in which
brett kavanaugh who had been accused by
a high school friend of committing
sexual abuse of her
cried his way through
the hearings in america there's a thing
about both white vigilantism and white
tears
particularly
male white tears
really white tears in general because
that's what carrots are right
they carrying out and then as soon as
they get caught
green water works wow
how does she still have a job she has
gone full-on racist and i honestly think
that the the the ceo whoever owns this
network doesn't watch msnbc because
reverse racism is racism but she is i
think because she's getting shellacked
in the ratings she's turned it up a
notch she is a full left-wing crank if
you had the right-wing equivalent of
that mocking uh weeping blacks and
mocking the black tears you would be out
the door before you got to that second
word tears so this is insane but you
can't just go after msnbc you gotta
throw cnn into the mix we're realizing
that the american media lied to us to
protect the rioters kenosha was never a
protest it was never a protest from the
moment it started it was a crime scene
right and it was a crime scene created
because an armed thug was rightfully
shot the whole protest lie was
fabricated for one reason and one reason
only it was to use it as another way to
emasculate the police that ended up
creating the vacuum which thuggery
exploited and then drew in a person like
rittenhouse who came to help because you
could see a city that he worked in where
his family lived was being torched so
it's all back to the media and i know
you're surprised i blame them but i
don't understand joy reid shouldn't that
shouldn't the the head of msnbc pull her
aside and say you do understand you're
saying white tears you were actually
could you demonstrate what your white
tier four no i can't sometimes sometimes
i will when you're on the chest
i do cry quietly in the break after
after you're on her all though
oh don't cry for me argentina
and whimpers he is at sixes and sevens
with you thank you for that ahead
liberal comedian bill maher out with the
big prediction
it's gonna make democrats furious find
out what it is
[Music]
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else